support at the moment it sucks doesn't
it then yes it's not a very good time at
all but on the plus side it has come to
light and things are being uncovered
that should be uncovered and people
hopefully will be brought to justice and
pay the price for the damage that
they've done to us court and we can move
forward from here into the future with a
cleaner sport for athletes to take party
which is what everybody wants looking at
what we've heard today am I right in
saying that as far as the iwf is
concerned you're in the clear sorry from
what the IWF has said today that
basically puts you in the clear because
there's all of this nonsense about
suspicious blood tests and that sort of
thing and from what we've heard today
from water that you are totally in the
clear there is absolutely no substance
what whatsoever to that well yeah and
the findings that the Independent
Commission gave was that there were
there was no substance to the
allegations and the damaging to very
damaging to me allegations made by the
Sunday Times and by the Australian
scientists doctors ashington in Paris
also that they acted on incomplete data
which is what was said and they drew
conclusions that couldn't be drawn
without having the full context
available and they'd cause damage I was
a little bit disappointed given that I
had submitted written requests to the
Independent Commission and specifically
to order say asking the water experts to
release their evaluation of my data and
they didn't quite go that far but I
think that they did underlying the fact
that that those allegations did not have
substance what abouts everybody loves
said who doesn't I mean you know he
brought the Olympics to London but it
has been said as part of this report
that he could not have been unaware of
attempts to cover up doping in the sport
is he the right man to lead the idle AF
out of this mess yes I do believe that I
think that he is a strong person I think
that he put himself forward to to run
for president when he couldn't as deep
pan said he couldn't been unaware
of the the state that the sport was in
and the changes that needed to be made
but needed to be in position to be able
to instigate those changes and to be
able to to bring our international
federation forward and get it run in a
professional manner with the right
corporate governance with everything
correctly in place and I do believe that
he's someone who cares deeply about four
and will fight to put those changes in
place and to ensure that the
International Athletics Federation
supports the clean athlete in their
right to to be able to compete on a fair
and level playing field and the public's
right to be able to believe in the
integrity of us brought how long is it
going to take to turn a corner it really
is one of its darkest days athletics at
the moment it's definitely going through
a very dark time but i think i agree
with the comments that i saw from said a
couple of days ago that actually the
darkest time is in the past now and that
we can move forward from this these
things have come to light and people
will be brought to justice for that and
we can move forward and I think have
confidence that our sport will be a lot
cleaner moving forward what are your
plans Paula my plans right now and I to
I think that there's been a lot of a lot
of criticism some of it just and aimed
at the the sport of athletics and I
think that now the people who really
care about athletics really should be
strong and should unite in moving
proactively forward together and getting
the right systems in place a much much
stronger anti-doping am full Integrity
Unit and much better governance from the
idle air moving forward so that the
sport that we all love can be be shown
in the crowd light and youngsters coming
in and now competing in Rio and in the
future can know that they will be
competing on a level and fair playing
field you fancy getting involved at all
with the iwf in the future I am yeah I
mean I'm not particularly interested in
the politics side of it but in terms of
helping and making sure that us for does
continue to be run
where will be run well and does continue
to be a great sport and a sport that we
want our children to get involved in yes
that's something i do feel very strongly
about i think as a parent and as
somebody who has a lot to be grateful
for in terms of what athletics has given
to me as a person and then i think that
i would like to make sure that my
children come if they want to take up
that sport and the other children can
get involved in that sport and know that
they can reach their full potential and
have that reflective fairly and the
results okay